it had been quiet in the desean watson
litigation for nearly three weeks i
firmly believed it was quiet because the
lawyers were talking about
a potential settlement and it's come to
light in the past couple of days
that's exactly what's gone on tony busby
took the initiative he's the person who
represents
the 22 women who are suing desean watson
busby said the other night to mark
berman of fox 26 in houston the
settlement is not happening and he had
more things to say including
that his clients believe that the nfl's
investigative process is not showing
them due respect the nfl responded to
that in a statement yesterday you can
find that
at pft obviously the nfl believes it's
handling everything
properly as it tries to investigate
these claims but i think the most
significant development miles came
yesterday when rusty harden
who represents desean watson had this to
say in a recent interview mr busby
stated that a settlement is not
happening
we certainly agree that there are
currently no settlement negotiations
being conducted
while we have never approached mr busby
about a settlement
he has approached us on numerous
occasions in the past about the
possibility of a settlement
we have made clear all along that there
would be no settlement
unless the terms are made public and all
participants
are allowed to speak in their own
defense at all times we want
none of the participants the plaintiffs
or mr watson
muzzled by a settlement agreement mr
busby does not feel the same
here's what this means this means that
if this is accurate and i've yet to see
tony busby's
possibly inevitable response but if this
is accurate
this turns the typical practice on its
head usually when you're the one who's
writing the check
part of what you're paying for is the
confidentiality
because you don't want people running
around saying this guy's giving out free
money this company's giving out free
money all you gotta do is follow a
lawsuit
and you're getting yourself a lottery
ticket you want it
secret you want it quiet you want it
confidential
in this case based on hardened statement
harden and watson want to be able to say
look at how little we paid that tells
you
these claims had no merit buzzby wants
it to be quiet
because what happens is if it's quiet
people are going to assume
big checks being written by desean
watson
so again busby may dispute everything
hard and said miles
but this is so dramatically different
than the normal case
and hey kudos to hardin for putting it
all out there
i mean that's an aggressive move and
he's been very aggressive in his
defensive deshaun watson that's very
aggressive
to put that out there and and it speaks
to a level of confidence they have
in their case if it's true that the
amounts that have been discussed
are so small they'd have no problem
letting the world know what they are
right that's that's the interesting
thing to me it's
it's kind of like this is the first step
in sort of turning the public perception
um in i don't necessarily say in favor
but it's kind of what it is in favor
of desean watson you know it because
to this point it's basically been look
at all these cases
you can't ignore the fact that there are
22 cases
against desean watson you can't
necessarily ignore the fact
that there are upwards of 40 massage
therapists that he's used in the past
couple years
based on the 18 that came out with
statements
in favor of desean watson as well so now
i feel like when you hear something like
look we want all this to be public which
is honestly i mean it's not something
that i feel like i've ever heard of
before
in in something like this where
uh the pers where the defendant would
want
that all of this stuff out in the open
and to be able to talk about it publicly
and for
the plaintiffs to still be able to talk
about it publicly and for the settlement
my amount of money to be
also public that's very interesting to
me and i think you're right it must
speak to some level of confidence
that they have but rusty harden has in
deshawn watson
that this is going to work out
well for them now it's entirely possible
that rusty harden would still
seek a commitment from the 22 plaintiffs
that they not
speak to the nfl but if they can speak
publicly
who cares see so th this is just kind of
to me a tactical shrug by
rusty harden at the entire case
like we're not worried about it we're
not worried about it we we know what
tony busby is willing to take to resolve
these cases
and we know he's not willing to let that
all be public
and if i was busby and look he's kind of
in
checkmate here from a pr standpoint i
would be upset
because there there is an etiquette
involved where
these discussions are supposed to be
confidential so people can't speak
freely
you you you undermine the ability of
people to speak freely in negotiations
if
everything you say during the
negotiation can and will be held against
you in a court of public opinion
so it could keep these cases from
settling
but if they're talking about right now
a range of payments that would prompt
rusty hardin to say
yeah we're fine with this coming out it
tells me that tony busby
possibly is ready to move on it's
possibly he's vetted his clients a
little more carefully it was an
avalanche
of signing people up and i think once
you start asking tough questions
which may be why some of these
individuals were uncomfortable when they
were asked just
you know reasonable questions that they
regarded as tough questions there's a
lot of tough questions you're going to
be asked
and you're going to get to the bottom of
a lot of things and the folks involved
are going to realize this is a stressful
trying demanding process and there's
going to be a lot of people who are
who are asking us questions in a way
that make us think that
they think we're not telling the truth
so it could be that tony busby is just
ready to move on and you know what the
genius of this could be miles
it could be that harden now agrees to
confidentiality
now that he's gotten his message out
that it's not
your usual case where confidentiality
means
deshaun watson has written six figure
checks to everyone involved
so do you think that this is now going
to get loud again i mean that we're
going to
get these public statements between
busby and hardin
every day every couple of days like it
was sort of
in mid to late april you know before the
draft and
it seemed like every single day there
was something new do you think that's
where we're headed
well it's either going to get very loud
because it means the litigation is going
forward or
it's going to get quiet again because it
just dawned on me
that that that hardens statement
beyond the fact that it sends a message
that is very significant to anyone who's
paying attention
and he does it in a subtle way so it's
not obvious he doesn't come out and say
hey tony busby only wants 10 000 each
for these folks that's nothing that
shows it's just a nuisance that's
nothing that's a
that's a frivolous lawsuit that he's
trying to get result they haven't said
that
but but it could be that this is
harden's way
of getting that out there for the
benefit of folks like us who will then
explain what it means
and now they settle the cases with the
confidentiality provision
because i i kind of knew about this a
little bit
and that may have been the only
impediment
and if that's the only impediment and
harden is now comfortable going to
deshawn saying we can give them
confidentiality
because i've kind of made my point then
then maybe that's the path to getting a
resolution so i i still
will not be surprised if it resolves and
i think that the
competing comments this week were just
that
that one last kick that one last
effort to start the motorcycle you know
i'm not a motorcycle guy i never have
been but i know you got it you got
there's something you got to kick
and sometimes it takes a few kicks to
get the engine going is it a kickstarter
is that what it's called
and and this may be the last kickstart
to get the engine going so they can
settle the case
interesting uh yeah i'm not really a
motorcycle guy either i just prefer my
cars with three pedals so that's
basically all i know about that but
i do think that look if that's the case
then if these things
get settled if these cases get settled
um if they get resolved
then it also is going to start meaning
that you know
desean watson as a football player is
going to
start becoming a part of trade talks
again is it not you know because
that like that's that's the next logical
step because it seems like houston has
set up something
so that uh they don't need desean watson
anymore so that they can be prepared to
trade him
whenever these cases are resolved so if
that's the case then it
we're going to start probably ramping up
the trade talks about sean watson again
probably soon
dolphins eagles are the two teams i
would watch and if the cases are settled
even though watson will likely be
suspended by the league you can't have
these 22 claims with these tawdry facts
out there
and have no consequence given what they
did to ben roethlisberger 11 years ago
or they can they can do whatever they
want but once the cases are settled i
think that's when he's in play
to beatrice hi i'm mike tarico
and thanks for watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights
from nbc sports